Welcome everybody to another zoom all we have
Just a few questions one to do for five questions. So if you have a question
Do you need to get asked or you think it's up make sure you just chat it in
Start typing in the chat box and we'll get to you
I
Reminder to look at the announcements on the member site. There is a new announcement next week is Christmas Eve on Wednesday, so we will not
You have a zoom call on Christmas Eve, but we will have a zoom call on New Year's Eve
So that's the following week. So we will have a zoom call on New Year's Eve. We will not next week
Okay, let's get to your questions first questions. Okay, this was a question that wasn't submitted, but I
Had a case review this week and we I see this a lot on
my case review forms
And people ask this on case reviews. I thought it would be a good question to add to the zoom call
People have questions about metastatic cancer, so they
Think and I know you guys probably aren't anybody listening to this probably already done with this, but
It just seems so common out there in the world
about
People thinking that since their cancer has metastasized
that
It's a different cancer
So I get this common on case review calls and people initially call in and say a breast cancer. It's metastasized to bone
So how would you program a right machine? Do you have to put in bone cancer and?
and
Of course the answers don't because when a cancer metastasizes it's still the same cancer
So let's say if I have prostate cancer metastasizes to the bone. It's prostate cancer cells in that bone
So if I was going to have a biopsy of that bone
To make sure that it is cancer that's destroying the bone
They would see prostate cancer cells. That's why they would know that it's metastasis
Of that prostate cancer to the bone so the hit the definition of metastasis is that cancer is moved from its primary site to another site
That's what the metastasis is. It is still that answer. Now it is true that a person could have
More than one type of cancer at a given point. I have a number of patients right now
I think I have five people right now as patients that have
two completely different cancers so they have two
primary cancers
So they might have a you know, let's say they have an ovarian cancer and they have a lung cancer now a very cancer can spread to the lung
But is true a person could have two different primary cancers and if that is the case then we would have to program the right
For both of those cancers. Now would you have to change the program on a rife if I knew I had metastasis? I've gotten this from patients
You know a number of years ago, you know, I had breast cancer now. I just found it in the testicized
Do I need to change the rife program?
And the answer is no
because it's still
It's still breast cancer
cells in the bone
Now is there a time that you wouldn't want to update the frequencies on your rife or other reasons? Yes, there may be
so let's say I have
You know breast cancer and it's and it's um pretty stabilized and I'm really having a lot of issues with um my god, and I
did a
GI stool test and it's
Positive for h pylori
Could you decrease the amount of cancer frequencies in a given night and put more h pylori frequencies because I don't have time to run h pylori during the day
That's a good question, and that's a good reason to
update a person's cancer program
So I feel very comfortable doing that if a person's cancer
Was still very active and their cancer was growing still that's saying we're just
Hopefully just starting to put the break some of the cancers in a growth phase
But they're having a lot of gut issues, and they want to add h pylori wouldn't feel comfortable about doing that because you need to be running as much cancer program as possible
So that's really important so don't you don't want to
To take away from your
Cancer frequencies to deal with comorbidities
Unless your cancer is in a state of
You know relative remission so
um
But understand metastatic cancers are the can't the same cancer that's just moved to a different organ or the gold or whatever
So it isn't the different cancer on
Tastasis to the bone it's not bone cancer. It's still prostate cancer in the bone or whatever my primary cancer is
Okay, next question
thoughts on adding sulforophane to my regimen
So sulforophane is a great product and could ever could you will sulforophane be good for everybody
I would say that would be one the sulforophane would one of those nutrients
That probably would fit into that category
I mean, I have favorite supplements like
Nurbary medicinal mushrooms and things like that
Curcumin anti-inflammatories the flavonoids all those are favorite supplements because they could be good for anybody, right
Well, sulforophane could be it fit into that category
Oh understand when I do cheek swab testing I want
To test what's going to be specific for you
And if sulforophane doesn't come up positive on that
Does that mean if does that mean that if you're really
Preying about it you really feel glad that you should add that but you shouldn't because it didn't come up positive on the cheek swab test
Well, no, I again, I want you to feel like you can you make you're making your own decisions
You're praying about your own care
But I also don't want you to be
Making decisions based upon fear or some new
Instagram post you saw
It's you know read it. I was talking about this about CBD
There's a question about CBD later on
About how
If it's all over the internet about this or all over the internet about that and people are watching these Instagram
series Facebook posts or the these tic tac videos where it's basically a
Somebody who claims to be a nutritionist or claims to be a
naturopath but really they're just out there pedaling supplements
Now
Again, that's far be it for me to
Have a problem with somebody trying to earn a limited
Doing what they think is right, but again, I just think it's so ethically wrong
To just be pushing supplements and saying that everybody should take this or
These grandiose false highly falsified claims that many of these
Influencers may influencers make to push a supplement
Like she was reading was talking about it's all over the internet about this CBD product where CBD take it away
Pay to that is actually a question that we're going to talk about in just a couple minutes
Somebody asked that I take CBD for pain
Well CBD is not the thing you would take for pain
So it's just
It's there's a lot of
misrepresentation in the nutritional field
Um, you know in years ago we used to bash
Um the practice of medicine because there's a lot of misrepresentation
In the medical field with drugs
But it's almost worse than the alternative spectrum now
It's just really sad and um, so just be careful of that so thoughts on adding so horrifying to my regimen
I can't remember who asked this question
By all means if you feel like God's leading you to do that then I'm not here to tell you about to do that
But I didn't come up if it didn't come up in the cheek swab. I don't think that I would do that
Um, so it's
You could make your own decisions, but um, I you know, I'm not don't just
Search the internet for the next greatest thing or then listen to some influencers who's trying to push it
Have a little supplement
Next question would we be allowed to use cratum for pain management
We really do not love the idea of using ibuprofen and tylenol
I just try to find something more natural
Well, first of all, I would
Create them is is not natural. So that does not fall into the natural realm
um
My issues with cratum I have a lot of issues with cratum
Um, the biggest issues with cratum is that it's not natural and the sources of cratum
Are going to be very dirty that by that I mean you could get cratum laced with all sorts of things
Um, I
personally had and we had an employee a number of years ago
Who was dating a gentleman who was in his 50s. I think and he um
Was rushed to the hospital one morning because he had taken cratum that he had purchased somewhere. He thought was he was very
Um natural person and he was very careful on his sources too. I don't know what he was taking cratum for
But it almost killed him. He was in here
When the ER and it was laced with something um, you just to go and take
Uh a product that could be laced with ventral or something like that. I think it's just
highly inappropriate
It would be completely inappropriate for me to recommend that
I am very much against doing something like that. That's you know, I just go go down to the street quarter
A busy intersection and find somebody selling drugs because that's about what you're going to get
Um, we know somebody that worked at a
And it's to uh or help you people with um drug
Rehabilitation and that was a major drug that people were addicted to
so
I would
personally
As much as I would
Against taking drugs
I would rather use a drug that is more monitored and um
Out then that's something like cratum
so uh
You I would say don't
Next question. What do you think about sourdough bread in ration?
um, so this one came from
All our patient who asked great about this question, so I thought this would be a good question to pull the
Zoom call so sourdough bread is the biggest thing on the internet right now
Maybe it depends on who you're following but it's definitely a homestead um, big thing
A lot of people are making their own sourdough bread and sourdough bread has a lot of advantages over regular bread
Um, and I'm a big fan of sourdough bread over regular bread
It tastes better. It's better for you
Um, but again, there's some negatives
So negative number one is sourdough bread does not
Not contain gluten
So if you are stayed away from gluten
It still has gluten now it is true
We'll see a lot of testimonials out there of people that have issues with gluten that
Not celiac disease, but gluten-sensitivity issues
That say that they could eat sourdough bread when they couldn't eat other bread
Um, it is true. It has a less of a gluten load
But the sourdough bread that you make you also have to look at the flour that you're using
To make the sourdough bread
Um, if it's a natural iron corn or a natural
um
Type flour that is a more of an ancient grade. That's going to be much better
But it's still going to have gluten
So if a person does have gluten-sensitivity if we've done the
Cyrex array
Three array four array ten
And we've determined that you do have antibodies to
Gliann and its peptides
Then you can't have sourdough bread unless it's made from a true gluten-free flour
Um, if you're you we have not done those tests and if you if you're
How it would be I don't think I have gluten-sensitivity. That's not my issue
um
But you just put limit gluten on my food
Uh
Restrictions for cancer. Can I still have sourdough bread just once in a while?
Well, if you're just limiting gluten because I said that it's
Came up as a partial driver for your cancer
That eaten piece of sourdough bread once a week would probably be just fine
I would still try to get it sourced
Is in a natural
As possible because a lot of people are making sourdough bed bread from kills very flour or something
So if you're getting it from a natural ancient grade and you don't have a gluten-sensitivity
And I solely put limit gluten on your dietary restriction
And then I would say in ration if your definition of in ration is having it once a week
And I'd say you're fine with that
But if you have a gluten-sensitivity
And if I said no gluten absolutely no gluten on your um dietary restriction
Then you have to get it from a gluten-free bread flour source
Well, that answers that up there
There's the CBD question. Can I take CBD or a paid?
It's interesting
Because this is all over the internet by influencers penalty and CBD
Products that it's you know they can they go through this list of all these things that it cures
um, which is
A really big fallacy especially when you're talking about CBD because it doesn't cure anything
Well, it sounds like I'm being negative on CBD or not
I think CBD can be wonderful for many things but
It's not a cure for anything and CBD with that
If I was good if you're gonna say what are some natural things I could do for pain CBD probably wouldn't be on that list
So natural things you could do for pain
Um severe pain
Let's say pain from an injury or pain from cancer
Really pretty much nothing natural is going to help that
Now if you get muscle-sortus pain using arnica, usida, um a
You know anti-inflammatories which would be the flavonoids like respiratory curcumin
Aswellia things like that can be can be very helpful and can help calm the area and calm the the pain
But if you got pain from cancer pain from the tasticis
There is really no natural thing that's going to
Take care of that the only thing that would be close to that would be
A marijuana product, but not CBD. Remember there's multiple different forms of CBD
And there's a none of them would be anything that would recommend for pain
You'd have to get into the psychotropic form of what comes from marijuana the THC in order to really see anything
valuable in paid management
We've had people over the years take THC
for paid even smoky the marijuana
cigarette for paid and that was very helpful for some people now it partly depends
Upon the person some people are sensitive to
cannabinoids some people are
More or less sensitive to them
um
You know personally, I've never smoked marijuana personally
I've only tried the THC and the concentrated rick simsum
formula dose
And you know, I probably created a couple videos back in the day when I did that when my cancer was really bad
And it I will never do it again unless I absolutely had to
Because it made me so loopy. I just do not like feeling that way
So I'll never use any kind of medications like that or drugs like that
And I just don't like not feed
You'll be aware of my senses now
I would say it probably would take care of pain if you were taking THC in a dose that made you pretty loopy
The negative is is that it makes you pretty loopy. So
It's not necessarily a great choice either for that reason
And you could argue that well, I don't want to take more feed
I don't want to take these these oxycodiles. I don't want to take these addictive substances
Those aren't good for me either
Well, I understand that that's where you have to kind of make a decision
Now you could still take a medication for pain
We have a number of people that are on a federal patch and they can still function
They can still drive they could still work if they had to
If you were taking THC in the high dose that makes you the you couldn't function
You couldn't go to work. You couldn't drive. You couldn't do anything
So you have to weigh out those factors when you're trying to deal with pain
Now I don't think anybody should just
Just try to suffer it out. Pain just drags you down
It drags the energy out of you. It just it's not good for you
Now always whenever you have a symptom
Pain is a symptom. You do have to investigate why you have the pain
But if you're paying the reason why you have the pain was already determined
Let's add metastasis to my
To my spine and I'm having this horrible pain in my spine
That this will not go away
And you know you're you've already investigated
You know maybe doing radiation on that spot and you've investigated other treatments that that are
more
Evasive than you alternative things you're doing
Um, but you're still waiting on that or whatever and you just need to deal with the pain. It's pretty hard
to um
Not just go to the to a drug source to deal with that and it's
And to say you know as an alternative doctor that you don't need to do that you should just take this or you get
That's just not true
There's some things that we have to turn to medications for you know
There isn't any natural thing that's going to get rid of that type of pain. So
We don't want to be so alternatively minded that we were or dogmatic
About it um and then we hurt ourselves
So we have to be a little bit open minded to be willing to do some other things you could say that
You know
God gave men wisdom to make all sorts of things even though I might might be um
Benton not trying those things first
But um, well, we have to go to something that's what it's there for
Next question. I haven't started doing the coffee animals yet. Would that be a good next step
Um, yes, so
A lot of people are afraid to do coffee animals because it's gonna be messy. I'm afraid to do it because I don't have enough time
Remember in on the member site
There's the easy peasy way to do coffee animals. I also have it on the
The seven phases of detoxification
Site you know all I've access to that
easy peasy way to do coffee animals where you can stand to do it in the shower
Makes it really easy. That's how I always did a coffee animals. I didn't lay on one side of the other
Well, I just never did that
um
So I they worked for me they helped me a lot when I was doing them. I don't do coffee animals now. I haven't done them for a while
Um, but coffee animals have
multiple benefits not just
You know people think coffee animals are for well, I have
Constipation so I do coffee animals. No coffee animals are stimulate your parasympathetics, which are to stimulate
Your liver detoxification pathways to stimulate your immune system function
to
Parasympathetic stimulation calms your nervous system
calms your anxiety. It has so many benefits
um, and I always suggest people go on our website and look up sympathetic parasympathetic
And I have a video that explains the parasympathetic nervous system and I have some downloadable
um PDF some other ways to stimulate your parasympathetics and other ways to calm your sympathetics
But that's the reason why you do coffee animals. So yes
doing coffee animals are a good next step. Don't
Don't shy away from those or be afraid of them
Okay
That's all the questions that were submitted. Let's go to the chat first question with the chat to focus on gut healing
Is it best to put greed smoothies aside and instead eat cooked fruits and vegetables if so
And if I were to heat up my greens will be like a soup is that adequate
So um
Uh
If you're trying to heal your gut and let's say your gut let's say your cancer is pretty much stable
But my gut is the worst thing going that I just have never been able to heal it um
We have always recommended I don't know if anybody's
I don't know if this is a real big in the thing anymore, but
Years and years ago it was an insane and it was what's called the gaps diet g-a-p-s
And it was a gut healing diet and you started off in different phases
Of this gaps diet and really we used to take people through these phases and it depended upon how bad they were
Kind of what phase we'd started
So if they were just super autoimmune
Um, and did not have cancer
Then we would start off in the phase one gaps diet where we do just bone broth
That's all they would eat is bone broth for multiple days depending on their condition everybody was different
We didn't have just a set protocol. We dealt with everybody individually
But the old broth is got nutrition in it and people would we teach people how to make their own bone broth
And it has a lot of glutamate in it that's why it can be very healing to the gut
Well, we don't do that with cancer patients because glutamate is very healing to the gut because it stimulates growth
And it can be very growth
Uh grow growth of cancers. So we certainly don't want that so we would skip that phase if you have a diagnosis of cancer
Probably even if you are in complete remission. Well, if you're complete remission your cancers
You know no evidence of disease that
Maybe you could do a few days of that
Um, but let's say um, you're not so we're gonna skip that bone broth phase
But the next phase is basically just eating soups. You're not making bone broth out of the the meat stock
For the soup, but you're just eating soups. You're making yourself some chicken soup and you're eating soup. You're eating
It's soup is
You know the vegetables and meat products that are that are cooked so early
Um to excess you know the the carrots are very soft
The celery is even soft the meat has been cooked for you know all day long or multiple days
If you made a big pot of soup on Monday. It's now
Thursday and you're still eating that pot of soup
It's been cooked multiple days
So it's very pre-digested
So one of the issues if you have a lot of issues that you're got
You're you have issues with digestion remember the phases of
um
You're got what your dark gut does it has to break things down that's digestion
And when you have hindrances in digestion, that's why you would take digestive enzymes. That's why you take HCl
and um
and then to help with that process
Sometimes your gut wall is so damaged that if you're eating raw foods
That are not cooked. They're much more difficult digest. That's what this question is leading to
Oh my green smoothies those are you know freeze-dried vegetables
Yeah, they were they were partially cooked. They have to be in order to be freeze-dried and then they're ground
But they're not fully cooked
So green smoothies they would fall into the category of
juiced food where they would fall into the categories of you know, at least partially raw
food which I would say eating a raw food diet is hard for a lot of
cancer patients
Though again, well, there's people out there that advocate for your gut cancer. You should be eating a raw food diet
Which I think is foolishness because most cancer patients
You don't have gut issues too, and it's very hard on your gut to eat a raw food diet
but um
So that's what this question is alluding to
Eating soups would be a good things to do because it's fully cooked. It's easier. It's softer
Out of the gut. It's easier to digest. It's easier to absorb. You're getting that nutrition without
hindering an injury that got even further
so um
The question was would it be better to omit the green smoothies set them aside for a period of time and
um
um to end
Using things like soup as as um a choice instead and then you're added to the question
Not just not the powder but real greens vegetables powders
A bit of fruit hooked into a soup by all means
Absolutely, you could even if you let's get greens first and you wanted to add it to soup or something like that
I think it's got a mid-flavor so probably not really good. Maybe it would be good soup
but
Yes, if you had a greens on drink if you had the real greens that you were grinding up if you were juiced
You know carrot juice and then you added it to a soup and you cooked it all day in a soup
Yes, you're getting it cooked. You're breaking it down
so um
That's the whole idea. You're basically using heat to break it down
um
breaking down some of the fibers
That make it easier to digest and easier to absorb
Absolutely. Yes, you could do all of that
um
Similar to the question that we had last week or so that was about, you know, can the capsules themselves in my supplements
I think they're irritating my stomach. Can I open them up and just put them in my smoothie? Yes
um, you know
By all means that could be a good thing to do um so
You don't want things that are going to irritate your gut
So um you're not going to get your nutrition
Through any means if you have a really damaged gut
So we want to be working out of healing the gut
So continuation of the question the whole food not juices
So cooking is okay for the fiber and also taking triple fiber powder
Yes, yes, you can cook your food. Yes
Any other questions?
In the last time I had talked to you most you before Christmas
So I hope everybody has a wonderful Christmas and they have a great holiday plan with their family
Anything else before we say goodbye? All right. Well, you guys all have a blast
Holiday with your family very very Christmas
um
You prayed for everybody will be prayed for you
Uh, thank you for being our patients and trusting us and
don't
Know that we're
All
Reminded daily of our purposes to be in prayer and that's the biggest piece
Of help that we can give everybody so remember that you're part of that too. So we prayed for
All of our patients if you will
God bless you and we'll see you in two weeks now next week remember
Two weeks. All right. Bye-bye